to me there's nothing more interesting
in storytelling that when a character
undergoes a major personality shift and
one of the most important and powerful
changes a character can have is known as
a positive change arc this positive
change of character undergoes if used
correctly can a listen very strong
emotions and reactions from its audience
one show in particular on TV right now
that pretty much acts as a crash course
in the fundamentals of character writing
is my hero academia seriously it's
amazing and it has one of the most real
and engaging characters in anime right
now through kotsky paçoca
obsessed with winning to a psychotic
degree incredibly talented and downright
cruel at times I'm totally not mark and
this is how to write a positive
character
[Music]
in order to find a successful positive
change arc and get back to Jesus
sacrificed moment we all love your
character needs to begin his story
believing a lie to be true and over the
course of their story your character
will be faced with circumstances that
prove their outlook to be wrong
there will be struggle there will be
pushed back by them but eventually there
will be a tremendous moment of catharsis
so how did kotsky Baca go develop well
at a young age he gained his powerful
quark simply dubbed explosion this cork
is a combination of his parents
abilities his mother Mitsuki has the
quark glycerin which simply makes her
skin produce and glycerin like substance
while his father
mazaru has the quark acid sweat which
allows him to secrete acidic sweat that
can combust if friction is applied these
two quirks together gave bak ago the
powerhouse emitter type quark he now has
and with this explosive new quark baka
Co garnered an immense amount of praise
at a rather young age this phrase only
helped to sow the seeds of and develop
his superiority complex says or NIT any
matter as the years went on this complex
he had would only grow his court bean
use as an intimidation technique against
midoriya his core CLIs friend and i say
friend in inverted commas because they
sort of have a history where midoriya
tried to help baka go now this
particular instance is much more nuanced
than one might think the fact that it
was midoriya offering the help wasn't
necessarily the issue the issue was in
how Baco might have been perceived as
anything other than perfectly fine Bach
ago in his mind is a winner after all
and tobacco only weaklings need help
weaklings
winners this is why what's Midori
announces that he is attempting the UA
entrance exam and enters exam for the
best superhero school in the country
BOGO is extremely angry he wanted to be
the only one from the class to have the
guts to do it despite this however Paco
would later go on to rank number one in
his UA
entrance exam getting into the class 1a
with hero Eraserhead
as the teacher however it's here bucko
is faced with his lie and the reality of
the real world in the quark apprehension
test where each student's quark is put
to the test through multiple assessments
of their physical kind Paco would go on
to rank third being a placed by yo-yos
ooh and Todoroki two extremely talented
students with powerful quarks in their
own right when it comes to academics
Paco is also highly skilled however he
continued to place third for the midterm
exam a place once again by yo-yo rosu
and for the first time a day with
Todoroki coming in fifth this time
around Bach ago despite consistently
placing towards the top of the class is
undergoing a personal crisis and crisis
that he rationalizes as being something
to fix you either come first or you lose
in his mind and for the first time he's
a loser and this is where Paco go is
similar to Vegeta in a lot of ways he
isn't someone who concerns themselves
with wanting to be better and for others
to knowest Baca goes only concern is to
prove himself to himself
Bakugan accept a win unless it's
wholehearted there's no half-assing it
with this kid you either fight him 100%
or you get out of the damn way because
you're wasting his time a win that isn't
earned isn't real and Paco despite
having this warped outlook on what it
takes to become a hero is correct in a
lot of ways at times and that's
admirable this need to win this
superiority complex also stems from his
admiration of the number one hero all
might while someone like midoriya who
also admires all might believes that a
hero is someone who helps everyone no
matter the cost
böck ago believes that a hero should be
powerful that they should have a strong
will and never give up even in the face
of defeat a powerful hero doesn't need
help to win they just win
they're strong enough to do it on their
own and so therefore paco2 himself is
strong enough to do it on his own or so
he likes to believe as paco seen his
fair share of beatings and losses the
sludge villain the cavalry battle his
battle against all might alongside deku
and even is captured by the league of
villains but none shook him more to the
core that his loss against Deku in the
battle trial his first and only real
loss in the series thus far up until
this point Midori has shown no true
fighting prowess
yes he has shown that he can think on
his feet but nothing to the extent of
being able to win a fight
so for baka go to win should have been
easy but it wasn't midoriya used baka
goes anger against baiting him to fight
and give midoriya an otaku and opening
to win the trial there's a direct
parallel here with a moment midoriya
tried to help Buffy go out of the river
in his mind at least Tabaco misses
midoriya on a much larger scale exposing
him as a weakling only this time he has
no excuse this moment this loss it's a
turning point for bak ago and what seems
to be a point of no return for the
relationship between the two young
heroes and training this was the battle
that wounded baka goes pride and made
him declare that he would never lose
again this is the moment baka goes lie
that he holds to be true came face to
face with reality and he refuses to
accept it in this moment of wounded
pride where we first see the cracks in
the facade of banco he admits that he
could never defeat Todoroki in a fight
at his current level that he must keep
working that he will become the number
one hero thus further sowing the seeds
of his rivalry with midoriya this
rivalry would continue to grow and baka
goes anger would continue to fester from
simple moments like midoriya cheering
during the sports festival to him using
Bongo style of movement the actors of
Midori would continue to urge him more
and more and at this point
Baco had doubled down on his lie that he
kept telling himself he has refused to
rethink his outlook and as a result is
doomed to even greater failure further
down the line after the provisional
license exam but we'll touch on that in
a second first we need to discuss the
final exams the moment where Paco go was
forced to face his hero all night
alongside the person he seemed to detest
the most Victoria together the two
rivals would come together to face all
night
or escape for the exit neither of which
proving to be very viable options this
fight would be another moment where we
see the differences in Bakugan and
midoriya sense of what makes a hero a
hero while midoriya is scared and sees
all might as a god due to his power
Baco sees him as an opportunity to prove
to himself that he is good enough but he
doesn't need help and that he is strong
one believes they need to run the other
believes they need to fight
that is until baka go puts aside his
pride for one last-ditch effort this was
one of the most important moments in
barkos life he compromised albeit
apprehensively to work with midoriya in
this effort to pass the exam using his
fighting genius and Midori as tactical
expertise the tomb managed a plan that
inevitably allowed them to pass their
exam but not before baka go got a chance
to show what he's made of he realizes
that in situations like fighting all my
risks need to be made and pride East be
checked at the door and once done he
pushes his body to its absolute zenith
he tells Midori to run essentially
sacrificing himself so the two can pass
the exam as I said this mode is
incredibly important for baka ghost
character was executed he is brought to
tears drained of power beat resorting to
bison almost in a humbled attempt of
resistance baka go will give anything to
win even his pride fixings baka ghost
pride is something we've mentioned many
times throughout this video it's really
what his driving factor is at its core
his refusal to admit to feed his denial
of being beneath anyone even when all my
shows concern for him he shakes it off
and says he's fine bongos pride is what
made him tell midoriya to stay away when
he was kidnapped by the league of
villains he didn't want his weakling
peer to try to save him once more
further proving his own outlook wrong
and so here we are once again talking
about her Bongo always seems to find
himself at odds with midoriya in one way
or another baka gue really is the foil
for the hero of this story he always
seems the place that can fill to
midoriya and that will never be
something he will ever be content with
baka goes ideals would always contradict
victorious in some way he's quick to
anger
never
to fall to his insecurities and this
moment is the biggest development for
Paco go in this series one dynamic
changing battle against vitória their
fight after midoriya passes the
provisional license exam and baka goes
failure to do the same the hot-headed
powerhouse versus the overthinking
chosen one
this battle is bak goes anger laid to
bear he admits his guilt in thinking
he's the reason all my lost his power
and that it was because of his weakness
and failing to save himself that caused
all of this to happen he questions why
midoriya was chosen and not someone like
him he finds anger in the fact of
Victoria has progressed so much despite
always being the follower in the past he
believes midoriya is looking down at him
when in the end in reality midoriya just
wants to be as powerful as he is it is
here in this fight this culmination of
anger and guilt that Paco realizes and
admits to himself that midoriya has
finally surpassed him bak ago tells
midoriya that he will surpass the one
chosen by all might himself
their childhood hero Koski Paco is an
angry character who serves as the foil
and the rival to our main character
azúcar Vidura
in the way they fight in the way they
live in the way they treat people and in
the way they hope to be heroes its power
versus heart the climactic battle
between the two of them only cements
this and as director Joss Whedon once
said recognizing power in another does
not diminish your own that was the
biggest lesson Paco had to learn to
realize that he could be more than he
ever thought he could be as well as
heeding the words of Almighty when he
says that you can win by saving people
not just through sheer strength these
are significant changes and emotional
ones to see unfold in the character this
series and even this character are
incredibly well written I think Moens
feel earned very few things feel forced
and as a result these characters come to
life we despise Paco at the beginning
but throughout this series layers to his
character are revealed and we realize
that he is just a kid that has extremely
high aspirations for himself and is
willing to do what it takes to achieve
them which is admirable if not
respectable and watch him as he stumbles
and falls in becoming a better human
being
is in essence the magic of great
storytelling it's change its conflict
believable human change that we could
all relate to in one form or another
now baku isn't finished growing or
changing by any means and something
tells me we are in fir trees one of
these days coming and I personally
cannot with buck that'll do it for this
week I've been totally not mark thank
you so much for watching
you